like I in my research I learned that
Skid Row was almost called skid
marks is that true well I mean people
probably called us that anyways well
what they said they said that the band
was not named after the homeless
encampment in Los Angeles but rather you
guys were in a car and there was like a
near accident or something thing and
like the like a car went like and left
skid marks and and then someone in the
like saw it and said oh we'll call
ourselves skid marks that's not not true
okay well there we go that is not true
we have we have busted the myth do you
have uh Bahamian citizenship Bahamian
Bahamian yes I you do you have a
passport I was no I have a birth
certificate I was born in Freeport yeah
born in Freeport and when I go there
which is rarely they make me go in the
returning residence lot really so that's
kind of neat nice okay now the uh Legend
has it that skid R got its big
opportunity from Bon Joy that's true but
Bon Joy got all the money well that's
[Laughter]
true so how did that work out for you I
mean uh no but then here's what here's
the honest to God truth that is that is
true that we signed aing deal deal with
him then in order for us to sign it he
would take us on his tour and we were
just a bunch of nobody's so let's go on
tour in in arenas I mean that doesn't
happen every day okay but what I thought
it sounded like is that the publishing
deal with Bon Joy was uh not a record
deal so like what you what what you need
is a record deal what do you need a
publish deal for to get on tour with
Boni like like that's what it was cuz
that just sounds to me like some sug
night holding vanilla ice off the
balcony no I mean nobody held me off the
balcony but but no all I can say about
it is that there was so many bands at
that time right there was so many bands
and the ones that made it were very far
and few between like making it was like
a unicorn and I understand what you're
saying but here's what we did we had a
big I quit the [__] band when when we
when I understood what we
signed I said I'm not doing this again
I'm not doing this I'm not doing this
again so we had a big meeting with the
um lawyer Michael Guido who's now
Jay-Z's like right-hand business guy he
was our lawyer then and I said I'm
quitting unless we're redoing the whole
thing with Bond jilie and I get 25% of
everything in the band and there's five
guys in the band so that was kind of
ballsy but they said okay and then our
next record so we redid that we got out
of that and then our next record debuted
at number one on Billboard and it didn't
sell quite as many as the first but it
did very well that's the second record
yeah slave to the ground so you got in
there and and fixed that pretty quickly
right well I I just said I'm not doing
it again so I was like I'm out so it's
just so glaring that you don't need a
publishing deal you need a record deal
like a publishing deal just kind of
comes with writing the music the only it
literally is the same thing as sh Knight
and Vanilla Ice except just without the
balcony or it's like uh you know who's
the old one like like Otis reading
[__] [__]
like yeah well I mean I
mean you're right but but but I can say
is that right looking back I have a
great life and I I get to play my music
I have a new record out coming very soon
my new song is on the radio and so like
I mean you gota you gotta you got to get
a break got to pay your dues that's and
you have if you have a break I mean
looking back maybe it was worth it maybe
it was yeah you know what maybe it was
he put us in front of all his fans yeah
and we stole a bunch of them how big
were the show that he was doing at the
time oh they were that, no more no like
yeah like you know 15 Arenas we did
giant St Stadium
75,000 wow we did you know was the was
the New Jersey tour we opened every show
wow okay I was just a baby though I was
19 wow 19 and 20 and that was the first
time you started touring touring touring
no touring in arenas I toured before
that yeah yeah clubs yeah what what's
that jump like what's the difference
between doing going from clubs to Arenas
like is there just a VIP feel to it
well I had a problem understanding
exactly what you're saying and I would
treat it still like I was in a club and
that ended getting me in trouble like
like how like I would jump in and whoop
some [__] ass in the [__]
Stadium oh hell yeah I do that yeah was
like to the point of where dude you're
not in a club band anymore like you you
know like now the numbers are bigger I
was just so young like another mly crew
thing like one you know one time we got
kicked off the Bon JY tour because I
swore all the time on stage but that was
cuz you know like going to see Vince
Neil in Toronto his first thing he goes
hey Toronto look at all the [__]
[__] here tonight and he my buddy's go
wow look at all the [__] man this is
[__] great we thought it was
hilarious like that he would be talking
like
that wasn't like a ma it wasn't a mean
putting down it was just funny to me and
my friend we thought it was funny also D
Snider was H the way he would chew
somebody out if they weren't getting
into it or whatever it was just to me it
was like comedy and funny and like you
better get off your [__] ass and rock
are you with d SN yeah I love D I love
him he's funny we just had him on yeah
we had really a funny guy man he's
really funny he's really smart he's
really he's really you know like he's
he's humble yeah you know like the way
that he describes like just having been
like such an egomaniac so out of control
so impossible to deal with and how like
that just bit him in the ass and and
forced him into humility like it's
inspiring to talk to him it is inspiring
and he's in such amazing shape for his
age and and uh you know his wife susette
like that's a great team they've been
married for 41 years it's unbelievable
love love D do you like shopping on
Amazon I do and good news is sto's butt
wipes for your butthole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get sto's hot sauce for
your butthole plus sto's butthole
destroyer and sto's butt wipes for your
butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right
now yeah dud